Oh God no angles like sure yep there you
go
[Music]
okay so today we are going to try
couples workouts so couples workouts is
this trend on the Internet where it
really fit couples do these just
obscenely cute things to get and it
looks like a thankful us drink we
haven't done any couple specific
workouts before it would distract me you
know follow up with us you know I feel
like if you take those two things
separately like being really fit and
being really cute
that's a sight cuter than fit opposite
like I'm not cute when I workout right
I'm Austin ray I am Julian Baker we're
from New Orleans Louisiana and we are
fitness acrobats
we blend together a mixture of
cheerleading acrobatics gymnastics
martial arts dance anything that
involves movements we tried to find a
beneficial way to where we can use one
another a lot of this stuff involves
trust which is a critical critical part
in anything we trust each other
okay I trust you 100% right right but
like do you trust me to lift you up over
my head yeah yeah
coordination skills I'm a little worried
about this I'm really bad at balancing
myself I say that you on the other hand
are below no no no that sounds yeah so
first we're going to learn three
challenges which I'm told are very
difficult and then we're gonna practice
for a week see if we can nail it so the
three challenge is the first one we call
it the Machine one person is on the
ground kind of like a dead road person
is on the bottom grabs kind of like the
shin area person that's on top grabs the
ankles
Wow once that happens we're going to act
like a machine again I'm not so I'm
gonna be down here like this well you
also gonna raise your legs up first
right that raised my legs out up Oh God
and her ankles like Sarah yep there you
go it was hard to have the strength and
just balance to get you up baby legs up
lift your legs up this is why we're
trying it for a week so this next
challenge involves a lot of trust she's
gonna kick up into a handstand while I
catch the person who is in a handstand
to do a push-up while the other person
is holding the others ankles and then
they do a squat
maybe oh my god you got it I am super
afraid of doing handstand
yep I need to improve my chest that you
won't kick me in face
I generally in pretty good handstands
I'm worried that I'm gonna flip over I
keep thinking that I'm gonna fall and I
keep doing it really fast go faster
good go hyah just get over it thank you
Hey last but not least once again the
male is on the ground litzer legs up
ladies grabs hands once again extend
your feet out joy you're on your toes
I'm gonna push down once she doesn't
push up I press down as well and then I
come all the way up I mean you guys hey
guys okay so you're gonna do the push-up
first then you're gonna press down push
up for you push up for you you go and
you press down yeah now we're working 60
every spot we struggle I wouldn't say
it's harder than it looks
it's about as hard as it looks the main
thing was we were shaking this whole
time so can we not shake yeah I mean it
has to look pretty we can do it but you
know I think one great one is
interesting I think something good to
need this week you really need to
practice a little bit I think Ned and
Ariel can't improve more on not thinking
am I gonna get kicked in the face more
positive thinking more mental
preparation for them Herbert and why be
a great match I think that the biggest
thing that they were dealing with was
fear so believe in yourself scratch out
the fear and you guys will rock it hey
Ned starting to get up we're gonna go
work out
it was tough in the beginning we don't
normally work out together I think the
machine is the most tricky we got the
first position down but once we start
moving we get all like lovely and stuff
welcome back in the beginning we were
following almost immediately we went to
our gym and people were like oh yeah
feeling hot really excited about it my
hardest part was doing the handstand
when I was practicing that I fell and
like hit my knee
yeah we kept going it's actually cool
like to work out and to do something
together it's kind of fun the most
difficult with the machine yeah it's
hard to hold up your part here for a
long period of time like that yeah I
feel like the other part which is
strength so just had a day it went
better and we are just leaving finally I
think I mastered dancing at least
halfway through so we got the handstand
down and then my next problem was the
push-up I don't know why my arms are so
sore like after the first day it hurts
to touch it it's like muscles which
muscles wake up show me work on my arms
are like when I have to do a lot of push
up and put a lot of strength of my arm
started hurting I need a lot of push-ups
to prepare you did yeah one day I did
like a hundred push-ups I can't do that
many pushups and really the other two
were like very push up ahead of
definitely improving
machine looks good I think natalie has
the kind of before we have to just work
on doing it a few times
however can't hold the phone cuz his
arms are weak
it's weird cuz I can hold the phone for
a long time and I can't don't push it
I feel like our mental fitness improved
even though we may not have been
stronger we are more determined not to
let each other fall best part was being
able to spend time together when we work
out once we we've got like a chemistry
got that up better
okay so it's been a week and now we're
going to try Austin and Julian three
exercises together so we're gonna start
from challenge three and go backwards
since the first one it's a hardest out
you guys ready I'm ready
alright I do it ready
[Music]
the machine is going to be merciful the
most difficult ways the machine the
machine I think this is gonna be the
hardest it wasn't perfect but it was
better than any of the things we didn't
practice I mean I felt more comfortable
doing we got a good feet thing I mean it
was like not a shaky I felt like more
steady yes yeah
that's really all we can ask for is
better than it was a week ago yeah yeah
after a week of practice I think we made
some strides I think overall I went
really well I think we definitely
improved a lot
you work on something together you have
to be on the same page otherwise it
wouldn't work and so that was pretty
cool it wasn't easy but we supported
each other I'm proud of us I'm really
used to I'm proud of us too and I had a
good time I feel like I got spent a
little bit more time with you this week
yeah I would do it again because I want
more challenges it's really really fun
to learn a lot about a partner huge man
we're working out together is that we
don't need to go to a gym you can go
outside and use each other it's well
worth it and it's free
[Music]